quand j'étais petit garçon
je me cachais dans la maison en
tremblant tous les jours
parce que tous les jours je savais que
les parents mes parents elle est crier
allez vite vite vite vite vite vite
dépêche-toi vite mais bouge et j'étais
effrayé chez moi
prendre son temps
ça équivalait à être un fainéant vous
comprenez pourquoi je peux pas faire une
grasse matinée
chez moi
à confondre vitesse et précipitations
j'ai chuté bien souvent
comme vous à confondre vitesse et
précipitations j'ai pris des murs bien
souvent
oui très souvent je me suis retrouvé en
enfer
et l'enfer
c'est ça l'enfer
l'enfer c'est de saboteur
et ce saboteur au cours de mon de ma
présentation j'ai envie de vous
présenter trois choses la première de
quoi se saboteur est-il le nom en 1943
dans sa pièce huit clos Sartre avait
écrit l'enfer c'est les autres en 2022
je dis l'enfer c'est pas forcément les
autres l'enfer c'est votre saboteur
la seconde chose que j'ai envie de vous
présenter dans ma présentation c'est
comment est-il possible de le démasquer
au quotidien existe-t-il des outils pour
savoir quand c'est lui qui pense et que
c'est lui qui parle à travers vous et
troisièmement comment est-il
indispensable 1 de le neutraliser 2 de
l'anéantir si possible pour aller
au-delà au-delà de ces frontières
psychiques alors qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce saboteur dont je vous parle depuis
quelques minutes et certains
certainement se demandent ce que je mets
derrière c'est une super personnalité
psychique qui est très pernicieuse une
super personnalité qui est là pour tout
vous faire rater vos vies amoureuse qui
on le vend la main peut me dire qu'il a
déjà saboter une histoire d'amour
qu'il a déjà saboté un examen qu'il a
déjà saboté une compétition sportive on
lève la main je vois qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens lucides c'est toujours les
saboteurs qui fait faire ça
ce saboteur je lui ai donné cinq
facettes que je vais vous présenter
d'abord la première facette du saboteur
ce sont les pensées automatiques
négatives toutes les nouvelles
recherches on ne reçient de ces 20
dernières années ont dit que nous avions
à peu près 60 000 pensées qui passaient
dans nos têtes tous les jours et sur ces
60000 pensées
98% sont les mêmes et 98% sont les mêmes
depuis longtemps
si vous avez des pensées automatiques
négatives ce sont des pensées de votre
saboteur
la deuxième facette du saboteur ce sont
ce que j'ai appelé les émotions
négatives il en a trois la peur et tous
ces dérivés de la timidité jusqu'à
l'angoisse la tristesse et tous ces
dérivés dans les moments de blues qu'on
peut tous avoir jusqu'à la déprime et la
dépression profonde qu'on certains êtres
humains et troisièmement la colère je
suis un petit moment d'énervement
jusqu'à la rage profonde
le troisième facette du saboteur ce sont
tous les comportements autodestructeurs
vous comme tout le monde à un moment
donné vous vous êtes déjoué vous avez
non content d'être votre meilleur ami ou
amis était votre pire ennemi autrement
dit vous vous êtes tiré une balle dans
le pied la quatrième facette de ce
saboteur que j'ai découvert au niveau de
mes travaux de recherche c'est elle est
plus complexe c'est ce que j'ai appelé
le protecteur fossoyeur il y a des
fumeurs dans la salle
c'est votre saboteur qui fume il y a des
gamers addictogames qui jouent beaucoup
beaucoup 6 heures 8 heures 10 heures 15
heures et le week-end 17h par jour c'est
votre saboteur qui joue or toute
personne qui vit une addiction le jeu le
sexe la drogue l'alcool la cigarette
c'est le saboteur pourquoi je dis que
c'est un protecteur fossoyeur dans ces
4e facettes bah c'est très simple j'ai
bien connu j'ai fumé 25 ans et quand on
était lycéen étudiant cette période un
peu fragile on y va avec nos cigarettes
donc on se protège et en même temps
fossoyeur qui sait que quand on fume ou
quand on boit on creuse ça tombe
ce protecteur fossoyeur là est terrible
quant à la cinquième facette du saboteur
je l'ai appelé les masques alors Donald
winicotte quand il présente les masques
il dit que c'est un faux self je vais
vous présenter quatre masques la liste
est non exhaustive mais on voit que si 4
vraiment très clairs le premier masque
c'est le masque de l'effacer vous savez
la fille qui fait la plante verte en
soirée qui a du mal à ce que des hommes
viennent la séduire vous la connaissez
vous savez le jeune homme ou le monsieur
d'un certain âge qui aimerait tellement
prendre la parole aux réunion qui
viendrait tellement bouger mais qui est
incapable de parler vous le connaissez
ça c'est le masque de l'effacer le
masque du fanfaron
c'est celui vous le connaissez
certainement aussi qui est le plaisantin
celui qui rigole toujours qui plaisante
toujours pas quelqu'un qui a de l'humour
celui qui plaisait tout le temps tout le
temps au point qu'à un moment donné il
en est fatiguant vous le connaissez
la troisième masque de saboteur c'est le
masque de la personne qui critique le
critiqueur vous la connaissez celle ou
celui qui est jamais contente qui est
jamais content qui voit toujours le
verre à moitié vide et pas à moitié
plein celui ou celle qui dit toujours il
y a quelque chose qui va pas ça c'est le
masque de la personne qui trique quant
au quatrième masque et non des moindres
peut-être que certains parmi toutes les
personnes qui m'écoutent vont se
reconnaître c'est le masque de l'ultra
perfectionniste vous la connaissez celle
qui est jamais contente du travail qu'il
ou elle a rendu vous savez celle où
celui qui va reprendre 10 fois 15 fois
attention toi on a quelque part dans
cette idée la culture du fnao n'est ce
pas à la NASA failer is not un option
qui était d'ailleurs la phrase de Neil
Armstrong
je voudrais à ce moment de mon passage
vous dire un point crucial tout et tous
vous avez un saboteur donc vous devez
tout et tous vous sentir concernés parce
que je vous dis sauf qu'il est
complètement inconscient chez 98% des
êtres humains et combien d'êtres humains
font-ils un travail sur eux encore en
2022 deuxièmement vous pouvez évaluer la
puissance de votre saboteur par des
outils relationnels antisaboteurs que
nous avons conceptualisé
fais attention à ton mode de pensée et à
ta façon de t'exprimer ils peuvent bien
devenir la prophétie de ta vie qui a dit
ça Freud young Dolto Mélanie Klein non
c'est saint François d'Assise au 13e
siècle
ce symptôme au 13e siècle 7 siècle avant
les révolutions de la psychologie et des
neurosciences avaient déjà compris que
l'impact de vos pensées l'impact de vos
paroles à un impact total sur votre
destinée voyons maintenant comment vous
pouvez savoir que c'est lui qui parle
c'est lui qui pense et c'est lui qui
agit dans votre quotidien d'abord parce
que j'ai créé une langue dans mes
recherches qui s'appelle la sablangue
de même que dans 1984 George Orwell son
chef-d'oeuvre absolu avec créé la
novlang moi je dis que votre saboteur le
saboteur de tous les êtres humains de la
terre quel que soit leur langue quel que
soit leur continent parle en PPG le
premier P de votre saboteur c'est la
personnalisation dans votre tête il va
dire mais il y a qu'à toi qu'il en
arrive des choses comme ça alors toi tu
as le chic alors voilà c'est toi qui
fait des choses c'est juste faux mais
par votre saboteur vous le croyez le
deuxième P c'est la permanence le
bouddhisme nous l'avait dit et on le
sait normalement tout est impermanent
nous ne sommes déjà pas les mêmes qu'au
début du Talk mais ton saboteur il te
dit rien ne changera ce sera toujours
pareil
et cette permanence là c'est la
sablangue quant à la généalisation on a
plusieurs départements dans une ville
l'amour les finances les amis la culture
la santé le travail il peut y avoir des
endroits qui vont bien dans votre vie et
d'autres qui vont mal pour pas bon pour
votre saboteur votre saboteur prend la
peinture noire et perturbure tout en
noir ensuite votre allié votre saboteur
pardonnez-moi à des alliés il a des
alliés intrinsèques et il a des alliés
extrinsèques
les années intrinsèques c'est un état
d'esprit négatif
oui vous connaissez comme moi beaucoup
de gens qui peuvent être très très très
très très pessimiste
toutes les études prouvent que les
pessimistes utilisent moins de 50% de
leur potentiel quand les optimistes en
utilisent plus de 80%
voyons-en maintenant aux aliexprints du
saboteur ça peut être des petits coups
de blues comme un moment donné avoir un
mauvais temps pendant plusieurs jours
c'est un allié extra-secte du saboteur
quand il fait mauvais temps ça peut être
aussi des bouchons
et des bouchons durables votre saboteur
se réveille mais parmi les alliés
extra-sectes les plus importants je
pense au relations toxiques
toute relation toxique est liée à ce
qu'on appelle dans la méthode haute
qualité relationnelle une communication
qui a dominante basse qualité
relationnelle qui passe par des messages
il est quand même incroyable et c'est
mon combat depuis 30 ans dans mes
métiers qu'en 2022 a l'air de l'homo
connecticus du numérique a l'air de tout
ça les êtres humains soient au Moyen-Âge
relationnel personne n'a encore compris
que les messages toxiques que nous
appelons les toxicoms il en existe cinq
familles toxicomes de dévalorisation tu
es nul tu vaux rien tu es un zéro
toxicom de chantage de culpabilisation
c'est de votre faute dit le manager ou
c'est de votre faute dit le mari ou
l'épouse les toxicomes de chantage voyez
et l'indifférence non verbale génère des
relations toxiques toute relation
toxique est un allié extra sec de votre
saboteur
je vous invite tout et tous à faire au
moins une fois par an dans une
perspective d'écologie relationnelle
un check relationnel à cet effet
dites-vous cette relation elle est
bénéfique pour moi elle est énergie qui
gêne pour moi ou cette relation est-elle
toxique pour moi est-elle énergétique
à présent voyons comment d'une certaine
manière une frontière c'est toujours une
limite et il y a des relations qui vous
font rester dans votre zone de confort
et vous cantonnez en delà de la limite
alors que d'autres relations vous font
aller en deçà de limite vous savez nous
les psychosociologues souvent on aime
créer des effets par rapport aux choses
que les êtres humains vivent ensemble
dans des groupes et bien j'aimerais
créer un nouvel effet
ne limite pas tes défis défis tes
limites la seule manière d'aller au-delà
de ces frontières psychiques c'est de
défier ses limites et c'est une culture
qui peut se faire dès l'éducation dès
l'enfance je pense à cet homme ce génie
que j'adore qui un jour dans une de ses
conférences avait dit
avait dit c'est Monsieur Mike Horn
quand j'étais petit enfant j'avais 8 ans
9 ans 10 ans je courais le jogging avec
mon père
et mon père était un immense sportif
puisqu'il était dans l'équipe des
Springs box du temps de Mandela alors
évidemment à 8 ans je pouvais suivre
papa que jusqu'à un certain degré mais
j'avais toujours dans ma poche une craie
et à chaque fois que je faisais ce
jogging je mettais un très là où je
m'étais arrêté mais je me jurais
demain j'irai un peu plus loin
et j'adore cette phrase de William Reich
aidez les gens à aller jusqu'où ils
peuvent et un peu plus voilà l'effet
Mike Horn ne limite pas tes défis défis
tes limites pensez à ce sportif Renaud
Lavillénie quand il commence la perche
Renaud Lavillenie
est mauvais
et pendant des années des années des
années il est mauvais et ces entraîneurs
à un point tel vont aller voir ses
parents lui faudrait peut-être qu'il
choisisse un autre sport parce qu'il est
pas très bon Renault Lavillénie aurait
pu écouter son sabotaire et les parents
de le Renaud Lavillénie aurait pu être
des alliés de son sabotaire que nenni
Renaud Lavillénie encore plus sauté il a
installé un perchoir dans son jardin et
au lieu de sauter deux heures par jour
il a sauté trois heures quatre heures
cinq heures par jour et versez 17 ans
rogné a commencé à faire des perfs
et en 2014 Renaud Lavillénie bat le
record du monde de perche
tous les gens qui défilent leur limite
et qui jugulent leur saboteurs ont deux
points communs 1 ils sont déterminés
il ne renonce jamais
souvenez-vous le grand Winston Churchill
qui dit à tous les étudiants d'Oxford au
lendemain de la guerre never never give
up jamais n'a jamais
votre saboteur veut toujours vous faire
renoncer alors
en conclusion j'ai envie de vous dire
qu'elle sera jamais finie la lutte
contre le saboteur parce que tel libre
de la mythologie grecque il a une
proportion à repousser mais plus vous
lutterez contre lui moins les crises
seront grandes
d'une certaine manière elles seront
moins puissantes alors balance ton
saboteur
vous savez le grand Blaise Pascal au 17e
siècle dit disait ce qui fait le secret
des grandes armes ce n'est pas d'avoir
plus de vertus que les autres c'est
d'avoir de plus grands objectifs
donc augmentez vos objectifs et la
seconde chose que j'ai envie de vous
dire en conclusion il faut que vous
sausiez pour ça votre saboteur n'aime
pas les gens qui osent
osez visualiser de grands rêves aux et
croire que vous en êtes capable bref
devenez une magicienne et un magicien
d'os
en conclusion finale j'ai envie de vous
dire
c'est une chose que l'humanité fait peu
encore que si vous voulez aider
n'importe quelle personne dans votre vie
elle proche ou collègue ou étudiant
copains
à juguler son saboteur
à chaque fois que vous voyez quelque
chose de beau chez quelqu'un
dites-lui
parce que pour vous ça prendra une
seconde
lui ou elle il s'en souviendra toute sa
vie ou le ferez maintenant
à cet à vous de jouer maintenant je vous
remercie